- It's the incomparable Stephen A. Smith.
And to help me with the Week 14 Playoff Picture,
I finally found a worthy sparring partner.
Stephen A.I.
[Stephen AI:] Preposterous. Luminous. Frauds.
Creating Playoff Picture.
- Hello, friends!
- Hello, enemies.
- Man, I love you guys.
- Yous all counted out ole Joe Flacco!
- No, no, this is too much RIGAMAROLE.
- [Stephen AI:] Eliminating RIGAMAROLE.
- Yeah. Okay.
- [Stephen AI:] Deleting teams forced to start backup QBs.
- Dagnabbit.
- The spell is broken...
- [Stephen AI:] Jaguars, I'm so sorry,
but maybe take a step back.
- [Stephen A:] Awkward.
- Someone stop me if I'm out of pocket here,
but I'm gonna take a step forward.
But I'm the chill coach that everyone loves...
- [Stephen AI:] Let's spotlight some young stars.
- [Stephen A:] Damn, you put some sort of filter on him?
He looks PHENOMENAL.
- Mr. Un-un-un-un-un...LIMITED.
- [Stephen AI:] Sorry, the A.I. is slowly catching up to the Broncos.
Now adding a fringe team that will lose a Saturday afternoon Wild Card game.
- No, no! Anything but the playoffs!
- [Stephen AI:] Okay, moving on to the NFC.
- [Stephen A:] Do we have to?
- OH, but I wasn't in the MVP Race episode...
- [Stephen AI:] Eliminating Seahawks.
- Eh, we've been fading away for years.
- [Stephen AI:] Randomizing atrocious NFC South playoff team.
- Hi? I was told I'm the most reliable player in the division.
- [Stephen A:] Now let's INGRATIATE some teams that'll make everyone say
"THEY made the playoffs?!"
- [Stephen AI:] Watch this, Stephen.
How about them Cowboys?
- Stephen A., you stop that witchcraft this instant!
- [Stephen AI:] Now, you heard it here first.
The Buffalo Bills will be in the picture.
- Are we doing, like, a fun one?
- That take is TOO preposterous!
Let's pull the plug on Stephen A.I.
- There can only be one Stephen A.
- OH NO, IS THIS MY LAST TAKE?!
- Everyone say cheese!